Madhumitha Janagaraja
So, this is a P2 mask.
I'm just going to make sure that I put it the right way.
You pull it back.
Pull it down.
Adjust it.
Put it here.
So, I have rheumatoid arthritis,
and other unspecified autoimmune conditions. And the smoke massively
increases my level of inflammation, which sets off other symptoms.
What this has meant for me I guess over the last few weeks has been a lot of
brain fog, a lot of nausea, a lot of fatigue.
I would get incredibly sick. I’d be unable to eat, and throw up literally everything
that I took in.
It was really hard to do everyday functions, such as make breakfast or
do laundry or things like that, which are obviously very, very necessary to my daily life.